welcome councillors to this
extraordinary meeting of
council this is a public meeting being
streamed live to youtube and via the
council's website
the meeting is also being recorded for
the purposes
of the minutes i have been advised that
the live stream is now
up and running if for any reason the
public can no longer hear
or see the meeting over the live stream
we will adjourn
until the connection has been
reestablished
can i ask the governance manager to
explain the procedure for the meeting
and to confirm the members and officers
present
thank you chair um as per our virtual
meeting etiquette
please can all members keep their
cameras turned on
and their microphones muted please
observe the council procedure rules as
amended and speak through the chair
when invited to do so today's meeting is
being recorded i'm going to start that
recording now and you'll hear a short
announcement
this meeting is being recorded
all the discussions that will take place
today will be held in public session
if you've got any connection issues
please contact myself or martin
derbyshire to help you to resolve this
the voting today will be done by roll
call and will be undertaken in reverse
order so
in the meeting today in the chamber we
have the chair and vice chair of council
that's council pat and cliff and
councillor martin back at mbe
and sarah sternberg the solicitor the
council and monitoring officer
the remainder of the attendees are
joining virtually and we have
all bar one member of council with us um
on the call the council's three
directors are joining remotely
as is the section 151 officer and
members of the governance team
thank you chair thank you
are there any apologies
have been submitted before the meeting
however councillor p wright is not on
this call
yeah i believe uh councillor philip
wright should be
uh attending this meeting he was at the
pre-meeting only
uh half an hour ago so can we ask that
um
ict make contact with him and try and
get him
online please um
through your chair i'll make sure that
happens thank you
okay
declarations of interest members of
interest should have declared them to
the governance manager in advance of the
meeting
however i will ask again can members
please indicate if they have any
interest
to declare
i was just uh waving their chair uh just
this council barry lewis just to
highlight a personal interest as leader
derbyshire county council
and we're talking about vision
derbyshire in this vessel
thank you
as the chair as chair of council i've
received a request for this meeting to
be called in accordance with part 4
paragraph 3.1 of the constitution
i now invite councillor barker as the
lead signatory
to introduce the motion to be put
counselor barker
as per the rules of debate you have 10
minutes
all right thank you chair am i on yes
thank you thank you just before i start
i just
want to make it clear that obviously
this this debate
or resolution is is a is is about the
conflict of interest
uh that people holding leader leadership
positions at
two authorities is the main thing here
and and it's not a personal attack
on the leader or anything like that
um i would also like to acknowledge that
things have moved on somewhat since we
first submitted the motion
and but i do believe or we believe that
the main reason for the motion is still
valid
and and and they are two-fold
firstly to highlight the clear conflicts
of interest
not just on this issue but possibly
others going forward
when the same person is the leader of a
district council and the cabinet member
of another
related authority secondly we wanted to
unequivocally put on record the
council's full commitment
to the two-tier system that has served
us so well during this crisis
and and for a long time whilst we
welcome the fact that the leader has
signed the letter
to the secretary of state that was
circulated last week
which was coincidentally left well after
the motion before
before us was published and we fully
support the sentiments in that letter
especially the paragraph that states
that at the time of a national crisis
we believe the priority must be to focus
our efforts on supporting residents
businesses and the community now that
the second wave of the coleridge
pandemic is on us
but having read that letter i can't help
but refer back to the county council
meeting on the 16th of september
where officers of the county were and i
quote
mandated to prepare an alternative route
for the devolution
in the form of developing a case for a
single unitary model
of local government it was also agreed
at that meeting
to approve the submission of a letter
from the leader
to the secretary of state to request an
invitation to submit a proposal
for the single tier of local government
in the county
this work resolution were voted through
by the leader until other members
of this district council
and just as an aside can i ask given the
sentiments in the letter that was signed
uh last week have the officers at the
county been told to stop working on that
unitary model
uh my guess is probably not so he can
see where the
where the confusion and skepticism uh
has come from
um and basically the question is which
will the leader be riding when it when
any strategic
decisions have to be made about the
future local government in derbyshire
we and the people of north east
derbyshire
need to know that the person leading the
council is totally committed
to it and not half and half we believe
that the two roles that council dale
personally hold are incompatible
hence the meeting today and the motion
presented i would therefore like to move
the motion in front of you i believe the
main issue today is whether
you consider that a member of the
cabinet at the county council
can also be leader of a district council
i'd argue that these roles could create
a conflict of interest and as such
the leader's role is untenable i
therefore ask you to support the motion
as it stands
i just need a little bit of guidance now
do i need to read out fully
the motion as it stands or can we take
it as red
and and is there any way of putting it
on screen for
anybody that might be watching or do i
need to read it out fully chair
we'll see if we can put it on screen
hopefully we can for the vote but you
don't need to read it out at this stage
but we'll make sure everybody is fully
aware
before the vote comes thank you sarah
that that will save me a big job
so so i think everybody's aware what was
submitted
so yeah i'll move that as it stands
chair thank you
thank you
is there a seconder yes chair
um councillor barry will be seconding
this motion
um and i'd like to comment on it as we
move forward i'll take my opportunity
now
um i'd like to start by ensuring members
of the council
that this motion was not put forward for
political gain
but out of concern for the staff and the
council
we feel that the leader of the council
has his fingers in too many pies
and we feel the leaders roles are
conflicting and therefore we question
whether he can run this council
we need a leader who is committed to
observing this council in its entirety
a leader who is committed to the staff
who work for our council
and one who will categorically state
that this council is not going to make
any job cuts
a leader who will consult with staff and
the trade unions on all
aspects of the council's future
including any such plans
around division derbyshire or unitary
authorities
the leader has signed a joint letter in
support of vision derbyshire
but to ensure the success of vision
derbyshire you need the buy-in of all
the council leaders
what will happen if just one or two
decide that they do not wish to continue
we would like the leader to advise us of
what the consequences may be
should this happen and how will he as
leader of the council respond
staff are filled with stress and anxiety
as they do not know what the leaders
plans are for their future
what does vision domination mean for
them as the leader spoken to the staff
all this is adding to the pressures they
are already under due to the kovid 19
pandemic
staff are used to working in partnership
but they know that partnership working
means changes
so will the leader confirm again that
there will be no job losses if vision
derbyshire goes ahead
and i setting the motion
are there any other speakers
yes chair i'm sorry
doctor jonathan i was indicating his
wish to speak uh
counselor padal zombie
hello can you hear me yes okay thank you
thank you chair just just short comments
really
uh re-emphasizing what's already been
said but a little bit of history in
march this year the government announced
that colby 19 had arrived
and introduced a number of measures to
help and control the virus
northeast derbyshire responded to this
challenge
and quickly established the helpline
prescription collection hamper delivery
and distribute to the small grant and
medium grants to local businesses
which i know helped them quite a lot
almost daily updates were provided by
the council
and northeast derbyshire was recognized
as a national level
for being proactive and quick to react
to the challenges the area faced
then for some reason which i didn't
fully understand
the conservative party decided to change
leader
at this time the new leader said and i
quote
i'm determined that we will also be a
listening counsel
engaging with our communities in a
meaningful way at
every opportunity to ensure that the
decisions we take
represent the needs of those we have
been elected to serve
then on the 16th of december the picture
became a little more confusing
when a district sorry at county council
level
members passed a resolution there and i
quote again
for the leader of the council that's
derbyshire county council
to write to the secretary of state for
housing
communities and local government
requesting an invitation to submit a
proposal
for a single tier of local government
for the county
a number of northeast derbyshire
district councillors supported this
resolution
including the council leader
but what does that mean for northeast
arborsh if it goes ahead
well a single tier means no district
councillors
this group wouldn't exist anymore
the district would lose some of its
assets and facilities including land
and buildings and the obvious
reorganization and rationalization
would involve significant job losses
i believe there'd also be a lack of
investment in the area
and i have no idea what would happen to
ricknall homes
but most importantly it would mean the
loss of involvement
and control of local issues by local
residents
i don't know whether they can see me or
not but i'm into it
which cannot be right
hello oh yes
yeah most importantly a single tier
would mean lots of involvement of the
local community
and local residents which i cannot agree
with
i was elected to represent the people of
north east derbyshire
and before i decide which way to vote on
today's resolution
i would like to ask the leader the
current leader to explain his position
and demonstrate his support for
northeast derbyshire district
residents and employees by withdrawing
his support
at county level for any single tier
structure proposals
thank you chair thank you
councillor kenyon
thank you chair hello everyone um
is that right is it coming through yes
thank you
um yes i'm a businessman first uh not
really a politician so i have to say
these meetings don't thrill me
and i have seen a lot of bricks thrown
in all directions in this chamber
and i hope that for the rest of the
debates as it started we will
keep focusing on what the topic is and
how we can address it
in this case it's unitarization and
leadership and conflict of interest
first i believe unitarization is wrong
for northeast derbyshire
and i've yet to hear a strong case to
suggest otherwise
potential financial savings are cited
but my business experience has
taught me that bigger is often not
better because you lose flexibility
creativity and responsiveness and in
local government
you also lose accountability so i'm
really reassured to hear from many
discussions
and indeed this motion that that is the
view among our councillors from all
parties
but we live in an environment where
other organizations have different views
namely derby city and we cannot just
ignore that
our leader has a powerful county role as
well as leading our council the question
is how he uses that role
and make no mistake the county council
don't want unitarization
that view has been long held and his
wide vision derbyshire has been pursued
by
county and the the um the motion
referenced
in the in this motion that uh county
submitted does
make clear that the vision derbyshire
approaches is the preferred one
so we as a district council and our
leader in his county role
we can't take our bats home to get what
we want
requires engaging with the problem in a
tactical way
that will be listened to and some would
say
that this might put our leader in a
conflicted position
i believe the opposite it puts him in a
powerful position to get the outcome our
residents want
i also know our leader takes very
seriously his duty to lead
but not to control and they are very
different things
especially in the council and i'm sure
all those who have led councils will
agree with that
since becoming leader councillor dale
has demonstrated this in our cabinet
meeting
in our cabinet meetings in our approach
to leading and
indeed in the other roles i've observed
him in over the years
so i wish this motion was different and
i wish it had not
mixed up unitarization with leadership
and so on
so i could support it as it stands i
cannot
thank you chair
thank you councillor barrow lewis
thank you chairman um first of all can i
congratulate uh councillor barker
on his magnificent hypocrisy both as a
county councillor
and a district councillor on this
authority first of all
and secondly i'd like to say that this
is an absolutely shambolic waste of time
and council resources
when they're needed elsewhere
particularly at this moment in time
and we've got all these counsellors
sitting on the screen here um
just filling time uh because of a labor
motion
um that is uh not needed and is utterly
pointless
and a promotion which is completely uh
designed to whip up anxiety particularly
among staff
here at north east derbyshire district
council
i set out quite a clear agenda with the
the vision darbs your work and that is
to work
hand in glove with districts and
boroughs right across derbyshire
and even with the city um and
uh and primarily to get towards an east
midlands devolution deal
and in working uh to do that it's
entirely
right that the leader of this authority
particularly because there's an
application
or a letter written by dobby um city
council
um that the leader of this council looks
at
and thinks about and talks to us as a
county council and um
and under yourselves as district
councillors and look at um
voting and protecting the interests of
dogs of northeast derbyshire district
council which is entirely
what councillor dale did
um in voting in the way he did
i think we can all see that right across
the local government sector change is
happening
um and the three devolution deals which
were invited last week
indicate that and vision derbyshire very
much um as part of what we're doing here
in uh
in derbyshire northeast arms
demonstrates a very different
and clear way of working which is
one that works in in harmony with
districts and boroughs
so i won't be supporting the councillor
barker's motion
um of course and um i just like to say
um when it comes to this point around
the uh the conflict of interest of
course there is there are plenty of
of the local authorities right across
the country that have
dual hatters on cabinets and in
leadership roles
uh right across the piece we have two
here in uh in derbyshire
and so just to be uh just to be clear on
that and um and it
seems that councillor barker and um his
colleagues don't understand the two-tier
system
and don't even seem to understand how
politics works if they think this is a
way
of this way wasting people's time
is taking us anywhere near and forward
direction i'm afraid you're very wrong
thank you chairman thank you
councillor oscar gomez
thank you chair um yes i
i also found this motion totally
hypocritical
uh in july's fall council meeting
councillor barker said
that the uh it wasn't the right time for
changing leadership
and in the full council meeting in
september
it was saying that there wasn't enough
cross-party working
so this does seem to be totally
political
we're now seeing a second wave of coping
19 cases and we're seeing a high number
of cases in our area
and i think that what residents need for
their council
and the councillors be ready to help
them and not be wasting council
time with political stunts like this
thank you councillor tracy reader
thank you chair and just to sort of note
that i don't believe that this
is a waste of of council time at all
i think it's really important that our
residents
are fully aware of what's going on and
this is going on right now and i
i don't believe that it should just
disappear under the covered 19 cloud
so the points that i want to sort of try
and make sure that i make today is on
behalf of the red
residents and it is to try and get
clarity from
councillor dale and so that when we do
come to the vote that we
are making an informed vote and an
informed decision
i think the residents of northeast
arborsha deserve to have a council that
will place them at the heart of all the
decisions made about them
i believe we've been chronically
underfunded by local
you know the local government by central
government for a very long time
and i think that the public do
and contribute heavily to the services
and they appreciate having services that
are
delivered to them locally for instance
urban collections things like that
and i think they've appreciated all that
was going on
throughout the coronavirus pandemic we
saw lots of evidence of cross-party
working
before the change of leadership which
was going very very well
and we were fully fully kept
up to date and informed with regards to
what was happening and i echo a lot of
what counselor finale said in
in the beginning um when he opened with
his comments
now there seems to be a level of
uncertainty and i know the counselor
dale has
signed the letter agreeing with the
vision derbyshire strategy
and it does state that now's not the
time for restructuring local government
however i'm also mindful that
government's reasoning for suggesting
such a unitary authority
models is to save money and we've been
through a covert 19 pandemic which has
come at a significant cost
to local authorities so we can't ignore
that that is in the background and going
on
so i am mindful that councillor daler
signed that letter
but i'm also mindful that we've we've
got a big financial
uh issue that's probably waiting around
the corner
okay it is possible that um that
government won't give
district uh councils and borough
councils any option
uh but other to become a unitary
authority in the future and they might
reject the proposal um with regards to
vision derbyshire we don't know what the
outcome will be
with regards to that so my questions to
councillor dale would be is if this was
to happen
and they did reject that proposal how
would you seek to protect
those services and those locally
delivered services and and seek to keep
that democracy
closer to local people on the ground
so that they do appreciate having that
local connection to their counselors
and i know i've certainly seen that in
my community
um you know when i've spoken to people
and how do you um propose to engage with
the people of northeast derbyshire
um and if it was their wish that they
wouldn't want to pursue
anything you know around joining a
unitary authority council dale how would
you
uh you know respect the wishes of of
north east armship people if they didn't
want to go down that route
and that would be my question
thank you
councillor cupert
thank you chair um yeah i i think that
i'm i'm disappointed by this notion
that's been presented
and i've listened to both sides but i'm
also remaining disappointed by the very
fact of this extraordinary meeting
i echo the comments of previous
conservative members particularly with
regards to
councillor kenyan in relation to
unitarization
in particular councillor dale has my
full support as leader of this council
and i don't consider there to be any
conflict or issue
alongside councillor dale being an
experienced counsellor more than able to
balance different issues
but always acting in the best interests
of this district i think is what we're
always all trying to do
i would make the point that we all have
potential conflicts and it's about using
your judgment and experience
just for myself as a cabinet member but
also as a ward member and a parish
councillor
there's always the potential for
conflicts and indeed that was once one
of the first training sessions i think
we all had as counsellors
and you have to continue to use your
judgment to do the best for residents
and for the district as a whole
and i see no reason why councillor dale
can auditory is not doing that
as a second point i also want to place
on record my disappointment that this
meeting has been called today
all councillors as we said are here
today with the associated loss of
officer and governance time and
focus specifically at a time when we're
facing real challenges
businesses and residents are trying to
get through covered 19 and cases are
rising
again and i think this motion at a time
of this global crisis
but almost specifically at the same time
as the prime minister is about to speak
on the national
situation is quite a political
misjudgment i don't see why we have to
be here today rather than
just discussing this issue at another
full council meeting in the future
at its core what i think this motion is
trying to do is undemocratic
the conservative group received a clear
mandate from residents in this district
to form an administration
to run the district council and to
deliver positive change
council barca has acknowledged this
previously in the chamber many times
and over the last year we've been
delivering that positive change
even just over the last few months we've
been delivering for residents across the
district
by safely reopening leisure services
progressing the clay crosstown deal bid
during an immediate 500 000 investment
in clay cross to kick-start that
successfully bidding for and
implementing a multi-million pound green
home scheme
um an investment in at least 115 written
properties
and just from my portfolio as we
discussed at the last meeting we've
approved a major investment and
restructure of our planning and
enforcement services
and as we've already mentioned today
environmental health and street scene
have been supporting communities by
keeping services running
and also directly supporting businesses
with adapting to the restrictions of
covid
councillor dale as leader and the
conservatives as an administration
therefore
are delivering for residents and
improving our area at an unprecedented
and challenging time
locally and globally and so i reiterate
my disappointment that we're here today
and i will not be supporting this
solution thank you chair
thank you council alex dale
thank you chair i'm conscious just
before i start that quite a lot of
people have raised questions here and
i'd quite like to be able to respond to
all of them so i'm happy to
speak at a later stage if there are any
other speakers who
wish to go before i've had my hand up
for a while ask any questions
chair
can you see me chair sorry counselor
foster
yeah thanks for that i've had my hand up
for a while i think before
uh before the leader if i can come in
chair thank you
um yeah i do really uh
i've got to say almost resent being here
today and having my time wasted here
today
uh it's nothing i've come not to expect
from labor
at all um what was looking forward to
though is having this motion read out
because it's a ridiculous motion it's
hypocritical and i really wanted to hear
it and let the rest of the counselors
hear it
and any public listening to this and
have it on the record to hear how
ridiculous this sounds
so it's nothing answered before from
labor in my experience
i've always equated labor politics waste
extra cost and general incompetence and
here this is no different whatsoever
it's student politics and any public
watching here
if they looked at that motion and then
later on they see how we all vote
and we vote down party lines they'll see
that this was
just a political stunt all our time has
been wasted here
now much like councillor fernell said
earlier i've been elected to represent
residents and support the work of the
council and this this is none of that
you're just wasting my time here and
you're wasting the time of other
conservative councillors
maybe not labor councillors if you've
got nothing else to do but you're
certainly wasting the time of other
conservative councillors and that's the
case
what i'd like to know from from the
officers if we can put this to the
officers and find out later
what is the actual cost of this meeting
officer's time and resources
i'd like to know the costs and i'd like
to be told later on and later on we can
tell labor again how much they wasted
how much council funds
they wasted in putting this ridiculous
motion forward
and while we're talking some of the
language of here today
i know it might sound like i'm a bit
cross but when you look at some of the
language we've heard from labour
talk about what i've written down here
riding too many horses
fingers in too many pies now while we're
using that sort of language i can use
the same sort of language
question i've got for labor and you can
come back to me on this council council
of arka
how many fact packets did you need to
write this motion on
or how many beer mats did you have to
split to write this on that's what i'd
like to know
thank you chair
councillor dale
thank you chair i i'll try um my very
best to
uh to respond to the questions that
we've had uh
and try and explain it sure i did have
my hand up i don't know if
council alex dale would let me it's just
one comment but i didn't have my hand up
before he started to speak i'm happy to
give away
i'm sorry
council angelique foster yeah it was
just to say
um just to point out and i'm glad
uh further along when all the
counsellors spoke on this
uh the word was used but i just wanted
to point out
uh that neither councillor barker
neither
or uh councillor barry and
did mention the crucial words when they
were introducing their motion
which is the interests of residents
unless i've missed
i didn't i didn't pick it up from their
introduction
there was a word counselor mentioned
saw the interests of counsellors i
suspect that was meant there was the
words trade unions
so i suspect they meant the interest of
trade unions should be considered
and the interest of staff which we all
agree that you know staff members are
very crucial to our
organization but the crucial word that's
not been used
is residence so the interest of
residents is
what is at stake here and from my
experience that's always been at the
core
of this administration uh ambition and
commitment
to uh how they lead the district council
and i'm quite happy
to support the the currently the council
alex there because from my experience
that's also at the core of every
decision that he makes
when he makes decision at cabinet at
dubasher county council
or as a leader of the district council
so let's not forget that the residents
of north establisher
are the residents of derbyshire so it's
the same residence
interest that we are considering here
and it's for them that we are here we're
not here to represent ourselves as
councillors of the ward
we're here to represent the interests of
residents and it's just unfortunate
that councillor barker and counselor
barry both omitted that from their uh
introduction thank you
counselor dale thank you chad yeah
as i was saying i'm going to try and
address some of the questions that have
been asked
me directly and apologies if i um if i
missed some
i i think i'd start by um
following on from what councillor barker
and councillor funnel
fennell said uh they both quoted the
county paper the county council's
paper around the proposal for
unitarization but they didn't quote it
in full it says very clearly in the very
same paragraph
that that is to happen if vision
derbyshire is not successful
uh in in achieving the government's aim
so it makes
very very clear that vision derbyshire
is the county council's preferred
approach
and actually the the the model for a
whole county unitary is only a plan
b and i would argue and as i will come
on to argue
that was only in reaction to derby uh
city's proposal
um you know we live in in the real world
here and different organizations have
different views on these matters
um i view the dcc decision in response
to what derby city council
put forward which was a single
unitary authority in the southern half
of the county now that would clearly
have
uh massive implications on us it would
force us in the north into a
a a single unitary authority as well so
it would lead to the end of
north east irish district council it
would lead to the end of davis county
council
and if if the government was seriously
entertaining derby city's proposals
surely it's better i start from the
position it's better to have
all options on the table and allow the
public to have their say over this this
sort of an issue
so if the government was was
entertaining derby city's proposals or
was forcing utilization on us
then i would far rather have a situation
where we have all options on the table
and the public can decide
the other key aspect to this is the
white paper still hasn't been
um been announced yet we don't know the
degree to which this is going to be by
local choice or whether it will be
forced
so i think it's very difficult to um to
assess what's actually really happening
here and i see it as the
it's a a play by derby city council and
a counterplay by derbyshire county
council it's
understandable that those two
organizations would be
uh reticent about any other proposals to
um
to to sort of carve them up at the time
of the cut of the
uh the county council vote i made
absolutely clear at the time that i did
so without prejudice i made clear that
the district council
had not had an opportunity to discuss
this or consider this it's all come
very quickly and out of the blue and i
made very very clear you can watch back
the live stream of the video if you
really want to
but i made very very clear that the
district i reserved the right for the
district
to take a different position and that is
the position that i would adopt
um as i say the event the white paper
wasn't housed at the time
um there was a there's a vacuum of
information around devolution and
unitarization at the minute we don't
know
the extent to which you'll be forced or
or we have any choice in the matter um
and that the fundamental point now i
would add is that the vote at
dave county council was non-binding it
says
very clearly in the recommendations that
it's a non-binding vote
so i still have that opportunity to take
a different position anyway
um councillor barker refers to
uh canada cabinet member lead this
council well i'd actually argue that
we're all duel hackers
and councillor barca himself is chair of
north wingfield parish council
what happens when a decision
puts him at conflict between those two
organizations how does he handle that
we all have to balance different um
different competing
interests in our roles as councillors
we're all local members as well as
uh as having roles as leaders or chairs
of committees or cabinet members
so there are always cases where we have
to balance uh that position and the same
is true of councillor fennell as well
um councillor barry asked if uh
how we've been consulting with staff and
actually i would say that as a new
leader of the council that's one of the
things that i've really got off very
quickly in doing
we've had a number of uh coffee mornings
with staff
to meet them to talk to them to engage
with them we've had meetings with the
unions we've been down to the street
scene twice
uh to go out with staff and talk to them
and really find out what their
uh their views are and all of these
sorts of issues not single one i would
add has actually raised
the issue of unitarization or vision
derbyshire yet with me
i'm always happy to talk to staff about
it though
i also find it strange that she that
council barry is asking me to
to say that there will be no job cuts
with vision derbyshire
and yet labour have put a ringing
endorsement vision derbyshire
in this motion surely if she was
concerned about job cuts she wouldn't
put forward a motion
that says the council should pursue
vision derbyshire it's a bit of a
bizarre situation if you ask me i don't
really understand why you would
put all your support behind visioned
armature and then ask me whether there's
going to be any buckets as a result
it's very strange um i think councillor
fernell and councillor reader
sort of criticized the lack of
cross-party working
i think you have to accept i've only
been in the job for three months
and the first of those months was the
summer recess where councillors
generally speaking haven't met very
often
30 seconds left say against our chair
i think you were saying a few seconds
left 30 seconds left
thank you um sorry about that um i i
have started
the cross party viper meetings and i
intend to to fully pursue those moving
forward
and in answer to the there's a sort of
final question around
would i withdraw my support or vote a
different way at county
i've already made clear the initial vote
at county was non-binding
to enable the district to have its
position and i would of course take the
district's position
we have had that letter i've consulted
my group i've consulted the leaders of
the opposition groups
and we've all almost unanimously made
clear our view is that vision derbyshire
is our preferred approach
and our plan b is that we would resist
unitarization because now is not the
time for structural reform
the motion is completely unnecessary
it's a waste of time
in my my opinion and it is quite
political
i accept nigel's uh comments that uh he
he wouldn't wish to be seen as being
political or personal but
it does feel very much like you can't
ask for cross-party working
your time so palette
that's all thank you jeff
councilman
councillor morley
hello
mr molly you're muted
chair i think it's just he's got his
hand across his camera i don't think
he's wanting to put his hand up
all right thank you
councillor hill
chair counselor david hancock's
indicating his wish to speak
chair i will let councillor hancock come
in
thank you council hancock
thank you chair and thank you councillor
hill um
so councillor dale i specifically wanted
to hear what what he was saying to
to actually get his position on him on
this in my opinion is that unitaries are
bad
i mean they claim to save money although
the evidence suggests that that claim is
questionable
but they come at the huge cost of local
democracy and local decision making and
they
irreparably damage our local communities
as a result
one of my key concerns is platinum as a
planning authority we have an ability
the ability to shape the development
within our district
in the hands of a much larger authority
the defense offered by those district
boundaries will be gone
wingworth topton clay cross will be
swallowed as chesterfield expands
sherland will be swept away by all
britain so that historic countryside
will be gone forever
and when there's nowhere left to go
further south the northern greenbelt
will become fair game
and anyone pretending that drumfield or
killermarsh would be saved from
chesterfield's urban sprawl is lying to
themselves
i've known councillor dale for several
years now on occasion i've agreed with
his positions more often than not i
haven't
i don't particularly like him personally
but i've always respected the fact that
he has always
been one to pin his colors to the mast
and stand firmly behind his beliefs
and i absolutely respect that but i'm
struggling right now to understand his
current position
i know he's explained that but at the
minute it just seems to me that we're
flipping between one side and the other
and instead of the firm confident and
start response that i would have
expected from him
as leader of this council the letter
that he's distributed
is and i'll censor myself here it's
weaker than one's water
it's nothing more than a half-hearted
attempt at pacifying while he
strives to navigate the opposing
viewpoints
i disagree with some of the members here
there is a huge conflict of interest at
play
and i'm afraid on that on that basis he
is not an appropriate leader for this
council that's not personal
it is that conflict of interest north
east derbyshire needs a leader who will
serve this council
not be someone who's playing puppet to
matlock and for that reason i unreserved
and support the motion
thank you councillor hill
uh yes chad i wasn't aware that
indicating that i wanted to speak but
now you've brought me in i will just say
a couple of comments
and this the aim to counselor mark
foster
in councillor foster in 24 years on this
council
i have never never made a decision
on back of a [ __ ] packet or a beer mat
and i find your your comments very
very insulting not just to me
but to other members that we do care
about our residents we do care about
our communities and i think it's
disgusting that you try to lower us
to that sort of position
yes thank you chair um i'd like this to
go to a recorded vote please
yeah and just so that the residents
are aware of who's voting and
i'd like to second the uh the request to
see how much this meeting has cost us um
as a council
so again people can recognize where the
money is being spent
thank you
thank you are there any oh panther
welton
yeah a second the call for a recorded
vote please
i think do we need a third
thank you it's recorded vote um
any other councillors wishing to speak
councillor barker would you like to
speak
sorry chair you have a number of numbers
indicating to speak you have uh
councillor ross shipman and councillor
richard welton also indicating
and councillor joe birkin uh mine was
just for the recorded vote so to take
mine off it's a reporting vote
okay council shipman
thank you chair and then i just want to
echo councillor hill's comments about
uh councillor foster saying that it
seems to me that whenever council foster
disagrees with somebody so with school
ground politics rather than actually
accepting that we have differing views
which is the grown-up thing to do we're
in a debate
um but i would also like to point out
that
once again certain councils are missing
the point
of uh councillor dale's position it's
not the fact that he sits onto
authorities
it's the fact that he is juggling two
opposing views
one authority which he is in the cabinet
cabinet of
is pursuing one way the
other authority which he is leading and
obviously in the capital
is trying to it's got opposing views and
that's why
and with those opposing views which
which is the way
it's gonna have to sign up to one of
them he won't tell you which one that is
right now he seems to be wanting to wait
until this council votes
rather than actually in his um position
like it should be doing that's what
that's what he should be doing
and being leader isn't about making it
up and talking rubbish
i finish chair or is um any more
conservatives want to come in
we have no more interruptions as well mr
speaker thank you
being a leader isn't about forcing your
views on other people
but it's about listening to other other
counselors especially on this authority
and accepting their views and trying to
come up with a compromise in position
so you get the buying of the council
um time and time again we see councillor
dale failing to listen to people
um he's just wanting to force through
his own ideas
he has total total disregard for any uh
constructive criticism
as we're seeing in this meeting today um
and he's showing no signs it'll back
this council when push comes to shove
um i'm not going to repeat the fact that
it's it's it is untenable
uh because that's been said many times
by other councils but i i want to focus
on the fact that he says one thing
and he does another that's the problem
for me
he won't talk about the job losses that
will come off the back
of a unitary authority vision derbyshire
is basically a trojan horse
to abolish in this authority because
what it does is it reduces services
reduces staff
reduces the funding that we'll get and
that in itself
will lead to a unitary that's exactly
what's happening in northampton you
strip
all the services out you strip the staff
out and you end up with a unitary
authority
through the back door and he won't be
honest with you about that and i think
it's about the time he was honest about
what he actually believes in does he
believe in the unity or does he believe
in this district council standing on its
own two feet
councillor dale sat here just a few
months ago when he's thrown his and i
quote his friend under the bus by
getting rid of him as leader
i i voted against that at the time
because i didn't think
we should have been we should have been
switching leader for one uh and i
certainly didn't want it to be switched
to the leader we ended up with
because is his record speaks for itself
not just at this authority but
the county as well and i don't think
he's the right counsellor for
this authority and it's touched on it
today
he recently the letter that's recently
gone out regarding vision derbyshire
he says he consulted with all the other
leaders it was more of an
ask and ignore as far as i was concerned
because i fed back
i didn't think the industry was a good
idea i fed back that i believed
in derbyshire in itself would lead to
job losses and
reducing services and the way he paints
the pitch to the rest of the council was
as though all group leaders agreed
and that we all signed up to it as
though everything was hunky-dory
which is not true he knows it's not true
which is why
it it tripped himself up early because
he changed it from
all group leaders to nearly all group
leaders agreed to it
and that's the problem if you read the
email is sent out it was like
all group leaders read to his proposals
the other concern i have which is a
major one
right now pushed on it is the concerns
about
the white paper that's coming through on
planning it's another example where
council dale wants to take away
um democratic accountability from local
people
if that white paper is passed we will
end
residents in this district will have
less say over planning applications
at the time in which the applications
are put in so that being said
i have lost all confidence that council
councillor dale will ever put this
authority
uh at the front of his mind when he's
sitting on other authorities
and when there's political pressure from
his own party i'll be voting for this
motion and i hope the rest of my
colleagues sat on this council too
thank you chair thank you councillor
berkin
thank you matter of personal explanation
in relation to i believe
my speech earlier is understood by uh
ken
i would like to clarify that mata chair
point you've already just asked me to
speak
yes i would i was going to listen to
councillor birkin first and then to
bring you back alex
thank you very much okay
thank you thank you chair i have to say
that i'm disappointed
with some of the comments from our
conservative colleagues
um i don't think this is wasting time at
all as councillor foster said
and it's certainly not undemocratic it's
democratic to be able to consider and
discuss
and debate issues which are important to
the residents to the staff
and to the councils of of this district
council that's
that's what democracy is about i've just
seen a a chat line
seen by two of your colleagues
chancellor dale that this is this debate
is excruciating
it's not excruciating it's important to
know how people feel
so they know how this this district
council is being led
and which direction it's been led in um
you did not mention the
speakers before did not mention that you
had supported and given instruction to
officers to work towards unitary status
from the county council that's not um uh
choosing to decide your uh your views on
the late today and the latest
that's you've made up your mind it's
done and dusted i agree with council
cooper that
um we are we all have uh two hats to
wear
uh which could be decided to be defined
as conflict
the thing is when an issue comes up it's
what you do about that that's important
and the important thing what i've uh
been told over
over many years in uh various challenges
and what have you
is that if there is a conflict of
interest or like a conflict of interest
then you should withdraw you withdraw
yourself from that so that you are not
spoiling
the issue for yourself let alone anybody
else um
i believe it's important to to uh to
lead for
uh northeast africa district council uh
and i don't think in this sort of
situation
you can support the two conflicting
ideas
and attempt to ride both horses thank
you chair
councillor dale thank you councillor
dale to pick a point of explanation
thank you chad i believe that councillor
shipman has mistaken
uh what i said during my my speech i did
make pretty clear i know that time was
running out and i
maybe tried to get it across too quickly
but i did make pretty clear
that the position i've taken is that
which is in the joint letter which is
signed by all of the
eight district and boroughs vision
derbyshire is our preferred approach but
otherwise
now is not the time for structural
reform there are too many other things
happening at the moment
and i would i would always protect the
the uh position of the district council
just in relation to what he said about
um consulting other groups
i asked all opposition group leaders
i said that i was going to consult my
own group which i have done and i asked
all of you to to consult your groups and
feedback to me
and have engagement counselor shipment
you did email me back and i offered you
a meeting after to discuss it in more
detail
i didn't hear a dicky bird from you
after that i had a
productive meeting with councillor
fernell i appreciate he's taking a
different position but
uh that that that's fine it was a useful
meeting nonetheless
and i didn't hear anything back from
councillor barker so i
what views could i go on other than the
views of my own
uh group and my own group endorsed the
signing of that letter and endorsed that
position
wholeheartedly so i don't think it needs
any further clarity than that
so thank you chair
thank you are there any other counselors
wishing to speak
no no councillor barco
right
counselor tate will wave in his hand
does he want to go sorry
counselor tate sorry thank you just
moved to the vote chair
thank you
oh [ __ ] that
thank you can i just uh just come back
then councillor parker
just to summit all up yeah thanks
uh we started off quite well i think but
there's been a couple of comments that
that i could take exception to and i
think
councillor alex mark foster sorry
i think some of the language you use
when we're very helpful i can stand it
i've been called the
people have said a lot worse to me but
uh i think it
they were they were a hidden flair in
all that and
uh like i say i could take exception to
that
angelique foster and i did refer to it
because i said in the
introduction i think i've got it written
here about
focusing on the residents businesses and
communities
in our community in our thing within the
lecture that that's signed
so i think i think there is there and
it's not been a waste of time
i think uh we have like i said at the
beginning
unequivocally i think come down on the
side of this vision derbyshire
we have made it clear where this council
stands whether that would have happened
this level of debate would have happened
uh if we hadn't had this this motion or
brought this motion
uh i don't know but i think when there
is a consensus now
that that we're not in favor of big
unitary authorities especially at this
time
i don't before moving on to the actual
motion i'd just
pick on the points by councillor bali
and read reader about
reassuring all our staff uh and
and obviously communities and residents
about our intentions going forward
and even if it is you know to fully
support vision derbyshire
let's communicate that as well as we can
uh i do feel to be honest that it is a
little bit too
too little and too late you know signing
this paper
the letter at the 11th hour that that
were on the back of
of somebody else writing it and asking
people to sign
it i'm personally and it's it is
personally convinced that there
is a well-planned strategy on behalf of
the county council
nottinghamshire and leicestershire to
create unitary authorities
and then set to then have an elected
mayor i think it's something that
that certain individuals have been
working towards for a long while
so it's not been a new thing all this uh
it has
been in the background for a long while
uh having said that
uh i do still feel now the concept has
been put on the back there
like you've said the white papers been
been deferred a bit
the the culvert crisis has obviously
uh took priority quite rightly but i
think it is something that that might
come back in the future
so uh i i still go back to the original
premise that we need
a leader and i know this dual letters
and i know
i expected that comment coming about me
being a county councillor and everything
else
but in the labor party you can't i could
not be in the same position as alex dale
we cannot
have lead positions in two authorities
so
that that's a rule within the labour
party which i think
that's that's a good thing because there
is this conflict of interest
so we need a leader that that's
really committed to the safeguarding the
future north east derbyshire
history council and given that that
that's the objective
uh i think and with that in mind i would
ask
everybody to vote with your conscience
and not just on group loyalties
and vote in favor of the motion as it
stands so thank you chair
that's i will move to the vote as you
say
thank you councillor barker
we'll put the motion on to the screen
thank you and then we'll go to the vote
and hand over i'll lend over to nikki
thank you
the chair and members um on your screens
you should see
uh the first part of the motion that's
put forward today
that council notes and supports the
decision of all councils in derbyshire
to participate in the vision derbyshire
initiative
council supports input sorry supports
the principal envision derbyshire but a
two-tier system of local government with
councils working closely
together is a preferred structural
solution for delivering on the proposed
papers agenda of reducing
regional inequalities council notes the
decision of derbyshire county council at
its meeting on the 16th of september
2020
to write to the secretary of state to
submit a proposal for a single tier of
local government
for the county and to mandate its
officers to prepare a case in support of
a single unitary authority
council believes that the creation of a
unitary authority is not in the
interests of northeast derbyshire
residents
and opposes the creation of a unity
authority
council mandate officers within the
council to prepare a case for the
retention of nedc
as part of a two-tier structure of local
government
council also notes that the leader of
this council in his role as a cabinet
member at darpashia county council
supported the proposal to create a
unitary authority in derbyshire
council resolves to exercise its power
pursuant article 5 paragraph 5.1
c4 to remove from office the current
leader of the council
and proceed to elect a new leader who
will safeguard the future of nedc
for the remaining term of this council
in accordance with paragraph 5.1a
are you happy for me to move to the
recorded vote
yes thank you
so members um i will read the names of
members um
in alphabetical order going backwards if
members could clearly indicate for
against or abstain
four
that's the pam windly for
that's a nick whitehead against
answer richard welton against
councilman martin thacker mbe
councilman martin thacker mbe
kevin tate
against
councillors
diana rough against
pastor kathy rouse
that's for cathy ross
oh
casual row against
cancer ridgeway
for hazzarenik
against cancer reader
or pastor powell
against cancer pots
against that's the pickering
or casa parking
against
cancer morley
professor jerry morley
i'm just going to ask you to unmute
counselor molly
because molly are you unable to unmute
your microphone
cha i i believe it council moyes says is
saying for
lilly
is that lewis if so against
thank you council louis councillor kerry
four
councillor kenyan
um
second time i've been asked
four
that's the hutchinson against counselor
huckabee
i'm just going to ask you to mute
against
cancer homes
[Music]
a
i'm going to abstain
against
that's a charlotte cupid again
she has a susie cornwall
for
councillor cooper
against a bone
counselor pat bo
against councillor kevin bone
against
what's the job
for
jane barry
gains
thank you chad i'll just consult with
the team to confirm the vote
[Music]
chair the result of the vote is
30 votes for sorry apologies 30 votes
against
21 votes for one abstention
and the motion falls
thank you
jay can you repeat that please
sorry would you like me to repeat the
vote
that's 21 votes for 30 against
and one absention
not sure that was what she said first of
all she said 31
and 30 against yeah i got that
sure my apologies i i've written them in
the wrong boxes here so to confirm
the result as confirmed with the
monitoring officer and the team counting
is 21 votes for
30 against with one abstention and the
motion falls
thank you
version promotion's been lost and there
is no further business to be discussed
therefore i close this meeting
the next meeting of council is scheduled
for the 16th of november
thank you
you